vous le savez c'est la saison des
vendanges j'ai certains ont décidé de
joindre l'utile à l'agréable on va en
parler cette fois et oui je vous vois
sourire c'est à l'initiative d'une
vigneronne tourangelle que plusieurs
célibataires se sont retrouvés dans les
vignes outre le ramassage du raisin
l'objectif était pourquoi pas de
rencontrer le grand amour une opération
qui porte le doux nom de tiens-moi la
grappe ça ne s'invente pas alors est-ce
que Cupidon est amateur de vin réponses
dans ce reportage signé à Aurélie Renaud
sur cette parcelle de Cabernet Franc les
vendangeurs ne sont pas des saisonniers
mais des cœurs à prendre ces quatre en
main ils avancent dans les rangs en duo
tous sont célibataires en quête de
rencontre alors après s'il y a l'amour
de ma vie dans les vignes pourquoi pas
je pense pas vous avez bien cher
je cherche important mais je ne trouve
pas